.
>> SCOTT JENNINGS, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
.
>> THANKS, JOHN.
>>> SAN FRANCISCO MAYOR LONDON
BREED IS UNDER FIRE AFTER VIDEO
HAS COME TO LIGHT THAT SHOWS HER
MASKLESS, DANCING AND SINGING IN
AN INDOOR CONCERT OF TONY, TONY,
TONY.
THAT IS BREED ON THE LEFT.
THEY SAY SHE VIOLATED HER
DEPARTMENT'S OWN MASKING ORDER
WHICH CAME OUT IN AUGUST AND
APPLIES TO THE VACCINATED LIKE
THE MAYOR AND THE UNVACCINATED.
HERE'S WHAT THE ORDER SAYS.
PEOPLE MAY REMOVE THEIR
WELL-FITTED MASK WHILE ACTIVELY
EATING OR DRINKING, WHILE DINING
INDOORS OR WHILE TAKING IN LIVE
PERFORMANCES.
NOW, ACTIVELY BEING THE
OPERATIVE WORD THERE.
HERE'S HOW MAYOR BREED IS
RESPONDING TO THE CRITICISM.
.
>> I WAS THERE.
I WAS EATING.
AND I WAS DRINKING. AND I WAS
SITTING WITH MY FRIENDS.
AND EVERYONE WHO CAME IN THERE
WAS VACCINATED.
SO THE FACT THAT WE HAVE TURNED
THIS INTO A STORY ABOUT BEING
MASKLESS, NO, I'M NOT GOING TO
SIP AND PUT MY MASK, ON SIP AND
PUT MY MASK ON, SIP AND PUT MY
MASK ON, EAT AND PUT MY MASK ON.
WHILE I'M EATING AND DRINKING,
I'M GOING TO KEEP MY MASK OFF.
SO THE FACT THAT THIS IS EVEN A
STORY IS SAD.
>> TO BE CLEAR, THAT IS NOT
WHAT'S AT ISSUE HERE, WHETHER
SHE SIPS AND PUTS A MASK ON,
TAKES A BITE AND PUTS A MASK
BACK ON AND SO ON.
THE ISSUE IS SHE WAS INDOORS,
NOT EATING, NOT DRINKING, CLOSE
TO PEOPLE WITHOUT A MASK ON.
YES, VACCINATED, IN THIS
MINUTE-LONG VIDEO.
THERE IS NO ACTIVE EATING OR
DRINKING AND THE ORDER IS CLEAR
EVEN FOR VACCINATED PEOPLE.
MASKS ON.
THE MAYOR IS SUPPOSED TO LEAD BY
EXAMPLE.
AND SHE KNOWS THIS BECAUSE SHE
CAUGHT MAJOR FLACK LAST YEAR
WHEN SHE DIDN'T.
BREED ATTENDED A BIRTHDAY PARTY
AT THE FRENCH LAUNDRY WITH SEVEN
OTHERS BACK IN NOVEMBER JUST
DAYS BEFORE SAN FRANCISCO ROLLED
BACK THE REOPENING OF INDOOR
DINING.
DESPITE STATE GUIDELINES THAT
STRONGLY DISCOURAGED SOCIAL
GATHERINGS CAPPING THEM AT THREE
HOUSEHOLDS.
IT IS UNCLEAR HOW MANY
HOUSEHOLDS WERE PRESENT AT THAT
PARTY DINNER, THE PAPER SAID.
IF THE FRENCH LAUNDRY SOUNDS
FAMILIAR,S IT IS THE SAME
RESTAURANT WHERE GAVIN NEWSOM
ATTENDED A PARTY THE DAY BEFORE
BREED.
THAT MAY HAVE COST HIM A PRICE
WHERE RECALL CHALLENGE THAT HE
SUCCESSFULLY FENDED OFF LAST
WEEK.
SO DEMOCRATS WHO FAVOR COVID
RESTRICTIONS, THEY KNOW THE
POLITICAL PERILS OF VIOLATING
THEIR OWN GUIDANCE, WHETHER IN
SPIRIT OR LETTER.
BUT IN THIS LATEST CASE
INVOLVING MAYOR BREED, SHE SAID
FOCUSING ON HER BEHAVIOR MISSES
THE REAL STORY.
>> THE FACT IS, THERE WAS
SOMETHING THAT WAS REALLY
MONUMENTAL THAT OCCURRED.
AND THAT IS TONY, TONY, TONY,
THE ORIGINAL MEMBERS, WHO HAVE
NOT PERFORMED IN PUBLIC FOR I
BELIEVE AT LEAST OVER 20 YEARS,
THEY ARE JUST REALLY SOME OF THE
MOST INCREDIBLE ARTISTS IN THE
HISTORY OF THIS COUNTRY AND THE
BAY AREA IN PARTICULAR.
AND THE FACT THAT THAT IS
GETTING LOST HERE IS VERY
UNFORTUNATE.
>> NOW, YES TONY TONY TONY IS
GREAT.
THE NOSTALGIA FACTOR HIGH FOR
THEIR FUTURE.
THE 90s THE BEST DECADE, BY THE
WAY.
AND FOR LIFE BEING AWESOMELY
NORMAL HAD WE CAN SING IF I HAD
NO LOOT WITHOUT WORRYING ABOUT A
VIRUS.
♪♪
THE REASON TONY TONY TONY IS NOT
THE STORY IS BECAUSE THE MAYOR
OF A MAJOR CITY IS NOT IMPLYING
WITH HER DEPARTMENT'S HEALTH
GUIDANCE.
IF THE ACTIONS ARE STANDARD,
THERE ARE A LOT OF THINGS THAT
WOULD BE IN COMPLIANCE FOR THE
VACCINATED THAT WE KNOW ARE NOT.
THE GUY ON AMTRAK, WHO HAS A
BEER IN FRONT OF HIM AND TALKS
MASKLESS THE ENTIRE ALMOST
THREE-HOUR TRAIN TRIP FROM D.C.
TO NEW YORK BECAUSE MAYBE HE
TAKES THE OCCASIONAL SIP.
THE PERSON ON THE PLANE FROM LOS
ANGELES TO ATLANTA WHO NEVER
PUTS ON A MASK BECAUSE THEY HAVE
A SNACK ON THEIR SEAT TRAY AND
THEY EAT SOME EVERY TIME THE
FLIGHT ATTENDANT WALKS BY.
THE PERSON SHOPPING IN A STORE
THAT COULD HOLD A SOFT DRINK.
THE MAYOR MADE A CHOICE THAT A
LOT OF PEOPLE MAKE, SHE WON'T
COMPLY WITH THE RULES.
IF SHE THINKS THEY ARE TOO
RESTRICTIVE, SHE IS THE MAYOR.
INSTEAD OF ARGUING SHE IS IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THE MASKING
RULES WHEN SHE ISN'T, SHE COULD
ADVOCATE FOR ALL VACCINATED SAN
FRANCISCOANS.
EITHER CHANGE THE RULES OR LIVE
THEM INSTEAD OF DEFINING THEM
BECAUSE, AS TONY TONY TONY SAID,
IT FEELS GOOD.
>> WHAT YOU ARE LOSING IS THIS
GREAT NEWS STORY ABOUT TONY TONY
TONY.
>> IT IS A WEAK PIVOT.
BUT I THINK WHEN IT COMES TO
MAYOR BREED AND OTHER DEMOCRATS
IN FAVOR OF THESE COVID
RESTRICTIONS, IT'S THE
HYPOCRISY
OF IT.
IF YOU PUT RULES IN PLACE, YOU
HAVE OTHER PEOPLE HAVING TO
BEHAVE IN A